It looks like females on average have slightly more friends
than men. Since I can see that this median line
is slightly higher. That's what this black line is. It
represents the median or the middle 50% of friend counts for
females and for males. Now this difference isn't very large.
So let's zoom in to take a closer look. This box
for females and this box for males Represents the middle
50% of values in our sample. So, I think it makes
sense that we zoom in even more to take a closer
look. We should consider any values less than 250. Now, there's no
exact choice here, I'm just choosing something that seems reasonable, since the
bulk of my data is down here. After running this code, we
can now see that the bulk of user friend count is
similar for the middle 50% of men as it is for the
middle 50% of women. Its just our females are slightly higher for
friend count. let's look at actual values though and compare the values
to what we see in our box plot. We can look at
those values by using the by command and running a summary of
our friend count split by gender. So first, I want to include
my friend count which is the variable I want a summary of. I
want to split it over gender and I want a summary. Running this
code, I get an output of my table, which shows me the
minimum maximum values for both genders, as well as the core tiles.
The first core tile for women is 37 and that looks about right
in our graph. The third quartile or the 75%
mark is at 244 and that's all the way up
here. This means that 75% of female users have friend
counts below 244. Or another way to say this is
that 25% of female users have more than 244 friends.
Similarly for the men, we can see how the first
quartiles and the third quartiles match up to the box
plot. Now, you might have remembered that we used coord_cartesian
in the solution video from before. We did this so that
way, the table output would match our box plots. If we would
have just used the ylim parameter inside of qplot, we would have
gotten different quantiles that wouldn't match our picture. This is just a
subtle difference that you should be aware of when working in
R. Now, it's your turn to answer a different question. On average,
who initiated more friendships in our sample? Was it men or was
it women? Used some of the techniques that we just covered and
then write a few sentences explaining how you
came up with your answer. This second question won't
be automatically graded, but it's important that you
know how to communicate your analysis to other people.